Hello, today I'm Psych2Go's volunteer. My
name is Maykol, I'm 17 and I enjoy long romantic
walks down the beach. Today's article is about
people who tend to sleep late have a higher
IQ by Risha Maes. Risha Maes got to
study with Psychologist Satoshi Kanazawa
made a survey for people in their late 20s
as the survey showed right here. Kanazawa showed
that those with an IQ of over 125 tended to
go to bed at 12:30am and wake up around 8am
on the weekdays and go to bed around 1:45am
and wake up around 11am on the weekends. Those
of normal intelligence tended to go to sleep
from 12am to 7:30am on the weekdays and from
1:15am to 10:15 am on the weekends. Those
of below normal intelligence tended to go
sleep from 11:45am to 7:20am on the weekdays
and from 12:35 am to 10am on the weekends.
As you can see that's a pretty big difference.
Now, that doesn't mean because you go to sleep
later you're more intelligent than those who
don't. There's plenty of factors to consider
like some studies show that the more intelligent
people, women in particularly tend to have
children later on and have fewer children.
Which allows them to sleep in later on more
than the friends or family members. Another
important factor is that the type of jobs
that people tend to hold which is also a big
contribution to when it comes to a person's
intelligence. The point of the study is that
smarter people can adapt more quickly to changing
conditions and can sometimes adapt habits
that don't really make sense. While people
of lower IQ tend to restrict their activities
to mostly the day time. But everything does
have it's up and downside. Having less sleep
is not really that healthy for the body. Nightowls
can be more prone to sickness like depression
or heart failures. They can also be less reliable,
more emotionally unstable and more likely
to have an addiction or an eating disorder.
Some addictions can be like alcohol or smoking.
While on the upside for early risers they
can be more conscientious, persistent and
can co-operate better. They can also cope
better with academic requirements and receive
better grades which would sort of explain
why staying up until 2 am playing pokemon
would not give you good grades. Hypothetically
speaking of course not from experience I swear.
Some questions for you guys, is it better
to be a night owl or an early riser? Do you
tend to sleep late or wake up early and how
does this affect you in the morning? And do
you go to sleep late sometimes because it's
hard to fall asleep for you? Don't forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
enjoyed and also make sure to follow them
on Twitter, Facebook and Tumblr. Well, until
next time. See you guys.